ha sido de mucha
obviamente evolución son tratando de
mostrar que todo está bajo control pero
lo cierto es que el ambiente es cada vez
más fuerte y claro en que boris johnson
debe dar un paso al costado por supuesto
el primer ministro está tratando de
mostrar que todo está bajo control
nombrando nuevos titulares en salud en
finanzas en economía pero lo cierto es
que hasta este momento raúl se han
confirmado 16 renuncias dos ministros
senior como es era sabido y richi sunat
además de otros ministros del gabinete
vice ministros y altos funcionarios
boris johnson estaba tratando de evadir
las punzadas no solamente desde los
diputados del laborismo el principal
partido de la oposición sino de otros de
sus propios diputados del partido
conservador hablando de reducir los
impuestos y de otros asuntos pero lo
cierto es que el parlamento es claro en
que la situación con boris johnson
a veces más insostenible de hecho tres
diputados de su propio partido entre
ellos david davis que ustedes lo
recordarán fue uno de los primeros
negociadores del president el gobierno
de teresa me ha dicho que boris johnson
debe dar un paso al costado pero el
primer ministro ha dicho que no que no
lo hará pero lo cierto es que en estos
momentos la voluntad en el futuro
político de boris johnson no está
necesariamente en sus manos sino en los
diputados de su partido pero todo parece
indicar como ya lo estamos viendo que
por él no se va del cargo luisa pero
hablamos de lo que pasó ayer en las
renuncias importantes de estos dos
ministros vamos a enfocarnos en el de
sanidad en el de sally de gbit cuáles
son los puntos o claves de esta renuncia
si se ha dirigido hace pocos instantes
al pleno del parlamento para explicar
sus razones de por qué da un paso al
costado y debo decirles que fue este
discurso fuertísimo en contra del primer
ministro y de su gobierno recordemos que
en este país la historia y los
antecedentes son bien importantes
veremos qué sucede después de este
discurso un referente similar fue
después de que un diputado en un
integrante del gobierno de margaret
thatcher dio un discurso similar
explicando sus razones porque se fue
pocas horas después la entonces primera
ministra conocido como la dama de hierro
tuvo que dar un paso al costado por la
presión de los ministros entonces vamos
a escuchar dijo habló de la importancia
de la integridad y todo esto mientras
boris johnson sentado simplemente con la
cabeza hacia abajo mirando el piso salde
david dijo además que ha sido importante
ha sido el centro de la democracia
británica la integridad ha dicho que
boris johnson no está trayendo el país
junto
en off es en off ya es suficiente y ha
dicho que algo está fundamentalmente mal
dentro de este gobierno y que el
problema ha iniciado desde arriba ha
dicho además que es importante que se
revisen las acusaciones de abuso dentro
de la dentro del parlamento británico de
westminster pero boris johnson que trata
de respirar y sacar la cabeza después de
todo este escándalo y de estas orientan
compleja pues no va a poder hacerlo
porque esta tarde en el parlamento
tendrá que responder nuevamente